はじめ：こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
まさき：まさき取締役です！
はじめ：はい（クモを出す）
まさき：うへへっ
まさき：びっくりしたｗｗ
はじめ：はい。珍しく今日はちょっとしたゲームをやろうと思います！
はじめ：よ！ふたり：（ぱちぱちぱち）
はじめ：僕、友達から聞きまして
はじめ：しりとりってわかる？
まさき：んんわかる
まさき：バカにされた今？
はじめ：してないから
はじめ：しりとりって例えば～あるじゃないですか
はじめ：あん・・・
はじめ：こって言ったら
まさき：コアラ
はじめ：ラッパ
はじめ：パンダ
はじめ：ダーマ神殿
はじめ：あ～みたいなね
はじめ：あるじゃないですか
ｗｗｗｗ
はじめ： 最近ですね、そのしりとりのなかで、
はじめ：「存在しない三文字しりとり」
はじめ：と、いうのが流行っているらしいです。
はじめ：今日はちょっとこの、
はじめ：「ハー・マジオネエ」
はじめ：と、やってみようと思います。
・・・・・・・
はじめ：遂に反応しなくなったな...w
でゅははｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ：あの、で、やったんだけど、
はじめ：おもしろかった！めちゃくちゃおもしろかった
まさき：もうすでに？
はじめ：えっとどんなものかというと
はじめ：ま、名前のとおり存在しない三文字しりとりを
はあじめ：三文字でとりあえずしりとりします。
はじめ：三文字ぃ、三文字
はじめ：言う単語が、三文字なんだけども、この世に存在しない単語
はじめ：例えばち○こも存在するよね？
まさき：んふふふｗ
はじめ：う○こも存在するから、そういうのはもう ダメです。
はじめ：存在しない三文字の単語を言うという仕組みでございます。
はじめ：今言った、この世に存在しない単語かつ、真ん中に「ん」が入らないとダメらしいです。
まさき：難しい　　はじめ：難しい。結構難しいです。
はじめ：調べれば結構ろいろあると思うんですけども、それをこの、
はじめ：（バンバン）トゥトゥトゥ（バンバン）トゥトゥトゥ
はじめ：ていうそのリズムでやります。　　　まさき：あぁ、なるほどね
はじめ：で、存在するやつ言った瞬間アウト
はじめ：実際考える時間があんまりないので、結構難しいんですけども、やってみましょう。
はじめ：じゃあ、僕からいきますね
まさき：はい
はじめ：せーのっ（ばんばん）
はじめ：けんち
まさき：（ばんばん）
まさき：ちんと
まさき：ふぁふぁふぁｗｗｗｗ
はじめ：とんぴ
（ばんばん）
まさき：ぴんこ
ひゃははははｗｗｗｗｗｗ
まさき：ピン子じゃんｗｗ
はじめ：もうアウトだからｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗ
まさき：ちがう、なんか、ひとつ言わせて、「ち」で送ってくるのずるくない？ｗ
はじめ：いや、なんか、多いんだよｗ
はじめ：なんか、間に「ん」が入る下ネ...なんかそういうあるじゃん？
はじめ：だから、真ん中にンが入る割と不適切な表現のある単語って多いから、
まさき：せーのっ（ばんばん）
まさき：なんち
（ばんばん） はじめ：ちんあ
（ばんばん）
まさき：あんと
はじめ：とんい
（ばんばん）
まさき：いんでゅふぅぅぅｗｗｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ：絶対"ピー"(いん○)って言おうとしたでしょｗ　　　　　まさき：ちがうちがうちがうｗ
まさき：ちがうよ～ｗ
はじめ：絶対今のは「ぶ」か「ぽ」かくらいしか
まさき：インコが出てきた今。完全に。
はじめ：あ～ね。普通にいるからねそういう生き物　　　まさき：そうそうそう
はじめ：せーのっ（ばんばん）
はじめ：るんち
（ばんばん）
まさき：ちんた
まさき：あははｗｗもういやだｗｗｗｗ
まさき：ねぇずるいｗ　はじめ：なになにｗなにがｗｗ
まさき：ずるいよ～ｗ　はじめ：なにがｗ（キメ顔）
（ばんばん）
まさき：わんと
はじめ：とんう
（ばんばん）
まさき：うんか
はじめ：かん..た
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
(水溜りボンドのテーマ)
（ばんばん）
はじめ：るんち
まさき：ちん..くぅぅｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ（ナレーション）：彼の脳内には下ネタしかなかった。
はじめ：だめよ　ゆわんとーとたい（聞き取れず）ねぇ
はじめ：なんだっけ最初、ぴんこだっけ？ｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
（ばんばん）
まさき：けんあ
はじめ：あんぱ
（ばんばん）
まさき：ぱんと
はじめ：とんき
（ばんばん）
まさき：きんて
はじめ：てん.た
（ばんばん）
まさき：たんと
はじめ：タント完全に車じゃんｗｗｗ完全にｗ
（ばんばん）
まさき：みんけ
はじめ：けんか
はじめ：あ、喧嘩じゃねーか　うおおおおおおお
はじめ：無理無理全然わかんない　ぜんぜんわかんない
（ばんばん）
はじめ：わんち
まさき：ちんけｗ
まさき：はははｗｗｗ
まさき：違うんだってｗ　　　　　はじめ：言お
まさき：同じのやってｗｗｗそれさぁ同じのｗｗ
はじめ：せーのっ（ばんばん）
~スピードアップ~
はじめ：えんち
（ばんばん）
まさき：ちんて
はじめ：てんぱ
はじめ：天パ！！！(天然パーマ)
まさき：あははｗｗｗｗ天パｗｗ
はじめ：ちん○ーーーーーーーー
（これが限界っすｗ）
(はじめしゃちょー終わりのテーマ)